what's interesting
earlier we're talking about the
challenge with david that you're about
to do i mean
that is a psychedelic experience of
sorts because you're biasing your mind
towards a pretty extreme neurochemical
state
and you don't know what you're going to
find there and that's kind of the
excitement
at least for me as an observer it's like
i want to know
what what the experience is like
afterward i want to know like how was it
i mean i'm sure you're going to get
something like you said you're going to
grow the question is how
and not resisting i mean it's the same
as with a psychedelic experience it's
like
not like giving yourself over completely
to the experience and
not resisting and going through the
whole mental journey of whether it's
anger or excitement or exhaustion the
whole thing
it's uh i mean uh
that's it the entirety of the process
that david goes through when he does his
own
challenges and so on is that whole
journey he finds
purposely like missile seeks
the limits of the mind that whatev
whenever
the resistance is felt runs up against
it and then goes to the full journey of
going beyond it and seeing what's there
on the other side well stress has these
two sides the limbic friction of being
tired and needing to get more energized
that's one form of stress
and then there's the feeling too amped
up and needing to calm down
the the typical discussion around
stresses is one thing
but it's all limbic friction it's just
that when i say limbic friction
that's not a real scientific term i just
mean the limbic system wanting to pull
you down into sleep or wanting to put
you into panic
and you using top-down processing using
that
evolved forebrain to say
i'm not going to go to sleep and i'm not
going to freak out
and those top-down control mechanisms
are i mean when those get honed
that's beautiful because then you real
you're increasing capacity for
everything
you